Erika Gerdes, how are you doing.
Hi, thanks so much for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
It's really wonderful
for you to be here on the show.
I'm really excited
to talk about authenticity,
talking about individuality
through your lenses.
Because you are a former
Google business executive,
spend many years there.
And you've taken a different route now
towards understanding a little bit
of who we are
and what we strive to be
and how to be our authentic selves.
So, I'm excited to hear from you
what that really means to you,
and how you help others achieve that.
Awesome.
I'm very excited to talk about it.
It's a topic that is
incredibly close to my heart and certainly
what I have devoted my life to.
Wonderful. So, authenticity.
Talk to me a little bit about
what does authenticity mean?
So, the challenge with authenticity is
it's one of those cliched terms.
And like so many of them
in this industry of self-improvement
or personal development,
that we don't really know
what it actually means.
So, the way I define authenticity is
the practice of letting go
of who we think we need to be
and embracing who we truly are.
Because I really believe that
when we embrace who we actually are,
we're able to have much greater impact
in our communities, on our families
and on the world around us.
So, just as a young entrepreneur myself,
and I'm always looking
at different startups
and different products
and I'm thinking of that now
as a product of how to help one
become more authentic.
And it starts always with a pain point,
what is the problem
that you're trying to solve.
So, I'd love to hear a little bit
about your journey
and how you transitioned
from your work in the workforce
to understanding that there is a problem
that perhaps people are not as authentic
as they could be.
To your point,
I was my biggest pain point.
And I experienced this emptiness
inside of me almost all of my life.
I called it the void.
Some people call it like a black hole
or just an ingenious
in the pit of their stomach.
And I thought I was alone in that feeling.
And I thought that the best way for me
to overcome that experience
was to do more, achieve more, be more.
And so, it led me to, basically a lifetime
of collecting gold stars
and doing everything I thought
I needed to do in order to be the best.
And in seeking perfection,
I completely lost myself.
And what I really began to realize is that
perfect wasn't even good enough.
I mean, it wasn't just perfect in my job,
it was perfect in all parts of my life.
I needed to be the perfect wife,
the perfect mother, the perfect employee,
the perfect homemaker,
like all of the things.
And in doing so, I was putting out
so many fires, I didn't realize
I was the one getting burned
over and over and over again.
And the pivot point in my life,
because I think every good hero's quest
has an inciting event, and mine was that
when my second daughter was born,
she was born with a tumor
on her spinal cord,
which we didn't know about
until she was two weeks old.
And it required that she have
a seven hour spinal neurosurgery
when she was three months old,
which was so far off of any plan
that I had developed
for how my perfectly curated life
was supposed to go.
That it made me
take a deeper look at my life.
She is okay.
She will have to have other surgeries
in her life, but I'll skip ahead to that
in case I forget.
But while I was in the hospital,
I had a thought that changed my life.
And the thought was:
I have one life to live,
there are no second chances, no do overs.
I get one go round at this life.
Why would I spend
one more minute waiting to be happy.
And what I realized was, I was in my 30s,
I had already been at Google for,
I don't know, nine years at that point,
something like that, and I didn't feel
like I was living my life.
I felt like I was living
somebody else's life.
And I had to start
getting really really honest with myself
about how and where and why
I was going through the motions
in all parts of my life
and start making changes
that enabled me to get back
to get closer to who I truly am.
And it's not something
that you make in one decision,
that's why I call it a practice.
Because we don't lose ourselves
or find ourselves or make changes
with any one grand decision.
It is these millions
of little micro decisions that we make
over and over and over which either
take us further away from ourselves
or bring us closer back to ourselves.
And so, that's what I teach now,
is how to listen more deeply
to what's missing and how we can begin
to find it for ourselves so that
we can begin to embrace who we are,
and what we truly want in our lives.
So, what was the most difficult part
of making that tangible transition?
So, I understand the mindset
that you're entering this
and you're accumulating
this inner understanding
that you're not necessarily fulfilling
your true potential for happiness,
and then there is a trigger in your life
and adversity that triggers that
and makes you realize, okay,
maybe I should do something about it.
So, how does that actually happen,
that transition to do something about it?
With a lot of crying.
I think the transition requires
we have to get to a place
where we realize that
we can't just keep being okay with okay.
And I know so many high achievers
and overachievers who you'll ask
how they're doing,
they're fine, everything's fine,
they're small problems,
I have nothing to complain about.
And when we do that, we're really ignoring
some deeper yearning inside of ourselves
that doesn't do us or the world a service
and talking about how fine everything is.
Yes, it may be, first of all problems,
but if we ignore those things,
we could actually, if we were to actually
pay attention to those things,
we could solve
a lot of third world problems
by actually paying attention
to the yearnings in our heart
and our souls.
And I believe that each of us
has the capability of changing the world.
But we can only do that when we start
by changing ourselves.
And so, for me, that change required
getting really really honest with myself
about why I was stuck,
what I was holding on to.
And the iteration for me included,
first, I ended up leaving my marriage
because I realized
it was never going to be
what I needed it to be.
And I had become such a different person
in order to be married
that as I became more myself
it just didn't work anymore,
which was on me.
And then I started
getting honest with myself that
while I love Google, I mean,
I was a preeminent Google cheerleader,
I was always a Google.
They have interviews that are like
a Googleyness interview,
which is literally determining
how googley you are, it was always me.
Like I can nail Googleyness
from a mile away because I love Google.
And I can say to myself,
I graduated from there.
I didn't leave there
because I really did love it.
But I found something,
that for me, I loved more.
And that was helping make a difference
in people's lives.
And so, it was incredibly hard
for me to leave.
And it has been the most rewarding journey
and transition I've ever made in my life,
also the hardest.
Right. It sounds like
a very positive transition.
But I have to grasp,
because there seems to be a fine balance
between when this transition happens.
Because one of the things that happened
as I transition into my college education
and I came into a university
older than most of my peers.
I was 24, most of them were 18.
I had commanded previously teams
in the Israel Defense Forces
and when I came in and people were asking,
I remember the first occurrences,
I was riding my bike
and somebody was riding past me
and they screamed,
"How are you doing?"
And then they continued.
I couldn't even have time to respond.
And I started seeing this
more and more often
that people are asking questions
about how you're doing.
But they're either not waiting for answers
or the answers that they gave me
when I asked them truthfully,
they're very on the surface.
And that made me think
about the society, in this race
that you're that you're describing
to become the perfect self.
But on the other hand,
without striving and without sometimes
doing as we're growing up,
things that we don't necessarily enjoy,
we can't get to be
an executive at Google, right?
Yes.
So, how does that balance work?
And at what point in your life
do you have to become more authentic
versus just going along
with what the society is telling you?
Well, I think that
we're always at a crossroads
at every point in our lives
to make a decision between
holding on to good and safe
or letting go of that
and going after what is great and true
and authentic for our lives.
And most of us never make that choice
to go toward what's great,
because it requires letting go of safety;
it requires letting go of certainty;
requires letting go of our comfort zone;
and walking without any guarantees
straight into the fog of the unknown.
And that's incredibly scary.
So, the younger we are, while yes,
we tend to be more risk tolerance
to a certain extent when we're younger,
most of us are still
very insecure with ourselves.
We're still trying to figure out
who we are just at any level,
whether it's surface or deeper.
So, for me, I don't think
it could have happened earlier.
I mean, there were so many opportunities
before I actually decided
to go down this road
that I just didn't take
those opportunities
because I just wasn't ready for them.
But I also really believe
that everything that we experience
is intended to prepare us
for what is to come.
So, all those previous times
where I chose good instead of great
helped motivate me.
Because I learned
over and over and over again,
I choose good, I don't feel good.
It is comfortable, or at least it's known,
but it doesn't feel good.
It just feels empty or it feels hollow
or it feels surface as you said.
It doesn't feel rich
and rewarding and full.
And when I experienced it enough times,
I realized I don't want to live a life
that by the end of my lifetime
I look back and think,
"That wasn't so bad."
I want to look back
and have been an adventure.
Know that I really experienced
full-range.
And full-range, what I've discovered is
I thought when I started on this journey,
that full-range meant
not being locked into a marriage or a job
that was holding me back
or keeping me down.
That's not what full-range is at all.
Full-range is about
being able to feel everything,
experience life fully, which means
all the joys and all the fears,
all the happiness and all the pain.
And when we know that
we can do all of that
and we will be okay no matter what,
we're not guarding ourselves
from those experiences.
We're throwing ourselves into them.
And that's what I hope for everybody.
Because so many of us
stay on these incredibly narrow paths,
just doing the same things
over and over again.
Whether it's in a personal relationship
or professional job.
And it's because we're too afraid of,
will we be able to actually make it
if we let go of this
and go towards something else.
And when we start to realize
we're going to make it,
no matter what we are going to be okay
even if it means risking everything,
that's when we get
to really truly live and have impact.
So, you leave the very intensive job
that you had at Google,
and now you're helping others
achieve their authentic potential.
So, what does that actually mean?
What do you do on a day to day basis
that is helping others
go through a similar journey
that you went through?
So my favorite thing at Google
was building relationships
and deepening connections
and establishing trust
is what I've always been
really innately good at.
And that's exactly what I get to do
all day every day, is listen to people
and hold space for them
to be really honest and vulnerable.
I mean, there are a lot of people
in our lives, if you think about
how much of the time
do you feel like you can
truly be vulnerable around somebody.
It's not very often.
And to be able to give people the space
and the gift of allowing them
to feel really safe, being vulnerable,
is in and of itself a great gift.
And when we allow ourselves
to be vulnerable and expose the fear
and talk about the stuff
that we don't ever want
to say out loud to anybody,
because we think,
"Oh, my God,
what are they going to think about me?"
"They're going to run for the hills."
Then we start to realize
that stuff is actually just,
they're just fear stories.
They're not real.
And when we can bring those things
to the surface, instead of ignoring them
or denying them or
pretending they don't exist,
then they stop having as much power.
And when we can take the power away
from those deeper things
that keep us stuck,
we're so much more free to take action
and make a bigger impact in our lives.
And so, that's what I do,
is I really help people identify
what those some people call them,
limiting beliefs, I think
they tend to be deeper than that.
I call them fear stories.
And most of us don't even know
that they're playing out
over and over and over and over
in our lives
and over over and over
in our heads.
In our micro decisions,
not just in the grand scheme.
So, it's in the day to day things,
that thousand decisions
we make every minute.
Exactly. Yeah.
So, how do you help people
go through that understanding?
It sounds like it's not just
a nice one hour Zoom call,
okay, tell me your fear stories
and let's get them out of the way.
It sounds like a more difficult process.
What is your role in that process
and how does the life cycle of this
look for someone who is working with you?
It's a great question.
So, I mean, it differs.
I don't have a process, a set agenda.
Like I used to be super processory
or relatively process oriented,
very planned and structured
in my work at Google, and now,
I go into every call completely unprepared
because I know I'm actually prepared
no matter what.
I can handle whatever is going to come.
And so, what I always say
to every client is:
there's no topic that's off the table
because the thing is,
no matter what topic we're talking about,
it's all the different doors
into the same deeper stuff.
And so, we don't realize it,
but we're playing out the same patterns
in our personal lives,
and our professional lives,
and our family lives,
and all these places.
And so, the way it typically looks
is that, especially for,
like I'll give you an executive
as an example.
An executive I'm working with
is talking about how she is launching
a new business plan to her organization.
And we start talking about
what's holding her back
from actually taking action
or how she's procrastinating
on writing the email or how she's looking,
and all of that stuff.
There is the surface power through it
and just get past it,
and then there's the deeper stuff of
why does this keep happening,
what is it that we're actually
battling up against.
Because what we tend to look at
as human beings,
especially in the workforce,
when we want to make a change,
we look at the tactical things
that we need to do differently.
What are the new skills,
what are the new habits I need to develop,
and that's great.
But that's actually
only about 20% of the issue.
The other 80% is the mindset
that keeps us stuck in those habits
and doing those things
in the same way we're doing them.
And so, if we don't look at the mindset
that is causing the behavior,
then you'll just see it
repeating itself over and over again.
And so, when we go into the mindset
and look at
what's yucky about that,
what's the most dangerous thing
about sending an email
that's not totally flashed out,
or that it may not have vetted
with ten people or whatever.
What we tend to come up with is,
well, people will think I look stupid.
Okay, what's bad about looking stupid?
Well, if I look stupid,
then people will think I'm a failure.
They won't trust me.
So, when we get down
to these deeper levels,
it is always about an identity
that we think we need to hold on to.
Some way that we believe
we need to show up in this world,
that we are so deeply attached to,
and if we don't show up this way,
then we risk no longer belonging.
We risk our worthiness.
And so, when we can detach ourselves
from that fear story,
then it becomes so much better.
Like, okay. Great.
So, I sent an email
that maybe not everybody loved
and some people might disagree with it,
but it doesn't impact my worthiness.
It just impacts this one thing.
Right. And I'm sure that so many people
who will be watching this
can resonate either on the micro level
or the macro level
with the things
that you're describing here.
What are some tangible things
that the average person can do
to help get over these fears?
Or at least try to embrace them
and understand that they exist?
Yeah. So, what I always encourage anybody,
whether you're, well,
most of us have goals,
things that we want to accomplish
whether it's losing weight
or it's taking on a new role
or it's just making more time for yourself
or creating more balance
in your work schedule,
so, whatever the goal is,
think about that goal
and then ask yourself:
what are the things I'm doing
that do not support me actually
accomplishing that goal?
So, for instance,
I'll say balance, work schedule.
Most of us over achievers
tend to like create a lot more time
on our work than we do
making time for our families.
Well, what am I not doing?
Well, I'm checking email
first thing in the morning.
I am emailing people back on the weekends.
I'm sending emails late.
I'm working on decks on the weekend,
whatever all of those things are.
Then we have to start asking ourselves,
what if I didn't do any of that stuff;
what would that make me feel;
how would I feel about that
if I just stopped;
if I actually just did what I wanted to do
and actually just create a balance;
what is yucky about that actual feeling;
and what we tend to realize is,
Oh, well, I have to do that
because what would people think
if I didn't reply back to them.
They might think that I'm ignoring them;
or they might think
that I'm not trustworthy;
or they might question my ability
to do the work, or whatever it is.
And again,
as we get to those deeper layers,
we start to see some of the
identity related things.
And when we start to see
what those identity related fears are,
then we start to see
how that's keeping us really stuck.
And so, it's always like asking yourself
what is yucky about or scary
or uncomfortable about
dropping all of the things I'm doing
that keep me safe.
Definitely.
Are there some higher level trends
that we're observing
as the workforce is dramatically changing
and obviously things are becoming
more and more and more competitive
as the time goes by?
I believe that most recently,
at least in Silicon Valley,
the number of years that somebody spends
in a tech company
is about two, three years,
which I think just adds
on to the stress levels of continuously
to improve and to gain to new heights.
Even though it's not something that
we might be actually passionate about.
Are there some higher level trends
that you're observing
or that we should be worried about
or optimistic about?
Well, what I am observing,
I'll speak specifically
to what you just mentioned,
is this idea that
we need to keep trading up
and things will get better as we trade.
Like, for instance, a lot of people
that I worked with at Google
left Google to go to competitors
thinking it's going to be better.
They had been at Google for a long time,
it's going to be better
when I go to this new place.
And it didn't get better.
It was the same thing
with slightly different scenery.
And that's what people find
over and over again.
It doesn't matter whether you're in tech
or in other companies.
And so, when we realize that the change
doesn't come from the outside,
that really is an invitation
for us to go inside, and again,
shift our mindset.
Because the scenery
is just may look a little bit different,
but it's going to feel the same way
as long as we keep those same mindsets.
And I just think it's getting
it's becoming more obvious,
and I think people
are starting to recognize some of their
limiting habits and patterns.
Especially because we have this
pressure cooker of being at home
and talking at Zoom
and all the other stuff
that's happening in the world right now.
Definitely. Definitely.
Erika, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
This is wonderful.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. I would say energetic.
Energetic.
Probably really really energetic.
Let's see.
Divergent.
Why divergent?
So, I call it divergent
because I used to think that, like,
I needed to ignore the parts of me
that didn't really fit in with the mold.
And the more that I realized
that especially, there are so many people
that are high achievers
and really intelligent people that think,
well, this part of me
doesn't really make sense
with the rest of me.
And so many of us,
when we give ourselves
to actually give ourselves permission
to be our full selves,
we are way cooler people.
And so, I say I'm divergent
because I'm highly spiritual and I have
a very perverted sense of humor.
I used to think those two things
could not work together,
but they very much do
because they're part of me.
I love intense workouts.
And my favorite thing to do
is sit outside and do nothing all day.
So, I'm very divergent.
And the third would be passionate.
I love it.
Okay. Erika, thank you so so much.
This was insightful and wonderful.
And best of luck on the journey.
And thank you for being very open
and honest about your own journey.
Yeah. Thank you so much for having me.
I'm really really thrilled
to have been here.
Best of luck to you as well.
Take care.